uh the targeting yet again of key
infrastructure in Ukraine what can you
tell us about these latest attacks yes
Sarah Jane I mean another round of big
attacks uh very big explosion in Kiev in
Viv uh in zaparizia as well around the
country and the Russians have been very
successful at targeting uh the
infrastructure the Electric electrical
infrastructure Ukraine made because they
know where it all is they built it it's
the old Soviet system so they don't just
know where the power stations are they
know where the substations are they know
where the small areas are where they can
break the lines of transmission and
apart from the explosion key of Moldova
neighboring country has a massive power
outage as a result of this this happened
just over a week ago the president Maya
Sandu is extremely annoyed about that
they've called the Russian Ambassador in
to explain it because Moldova is also
part of the system so when they hit
Ukraine they also put Moldova out
Moldova small country two and a half
million people it's very vulnerable it's
extremely liable to instability it
doesn't help them at all and of course
in zapparesia the maternity home
um only this morning the British
Ministry of Defense defense intelligence
said that the Russians are using drones
so they can prioritize uh medical
facilities as targets of opportunity and
it's what the Russians do serovicin the
commander he was famous for this when he
commanded in Syria they famously
targeted all of the hospitals and
medical facilities ahead of any other
attacks Because he believes that that
has a big effect on civilian morale
which indeed it does so sadly we'll see
quite a lot more of this I think yeah
horrific
um let's talk about the UK's continued
support of Ukraine sending these three
helicopters to the country uh tell me
about the helicopters and what kind of
effect they're going to have yeah well
it depends what they do with them is
that three people say well supporting
three helicopters these were taken out
of service in Britain in 2018 the the
Navy and the Marines they call them the
jumblies jumbly helicopters
oh jungley because of very useful but
the Navy mainly used them for
anti-submarine Warfare now the mod
hasn't said what these will be used for
but if they are used for anti-submarine
Warfare they could make quite a big
difference in the Black Sea because the
Russians are having a hard time in the
western part of the Black Sea the
ukrainians have targeted their shipping
really well but the Black Sea Fleet
includes six submarines of which four
are kilo class very modern very good
submarines which the Russians have got
if these are being used for
anti-submarine Warfare if they could be
used I don't know if they will but if
that's what they're there for if that's
what the six weeks training is for it
means you don't need six weeks to train
a helicopter pilot to fly a different
helicopter if it's anti-summary Warfare
they're training them for then that
might make a difference in the Black Sea
and just a quick word on her son of
course retaken by Ukraine uh civilians
being asked to evacuate is it still
active in terms of the war from what's
going on there no they're still fighting
there's artillery Jewels going on either
side of the river in cursing itself and
that's likely to continue but this is
where the helicopters become interesting
the ukrainians are fighting in the
kimbern spit that spit of land that that
moves right out into the mouth of the uh
the nepro river and the point is the
ukrainians have got that the western
part of that spit they're still fighting
for the rest of it but because of that
they have now got control over most of
the western part of the Black Sea and if
these anti-submarine Warfare helicopters
if that's what they turn out to be you
can see that the ukrainians are actually
gaining more control in their part of
the Black Sea which really matters to
them and meanwhile the Russians are
pulling some troops away now that
they've withdrawn from the other side of
the Nipper River and we thought that
they'd be pulling those troops out in
order to go right all the way through to
the donbass which is where the fighting
is still fierce but they're not all
going there quite a lot of them are
actually going to Melita pole and the
Russians are digging in a ballito pole
why are they doing that because they
fear that maybe over the winter the
ukrainians might might open a third
layer of a third direction of of a back
a third offensive from zaponesia down to
Melita Paul in order to put Crimea under
even greater pressure now that's a big
ask but so far the ukrainians have done
quite a lot of things that are
apparently impossible and they've found
ways of doing it in the analysis
business we're all asking if they can do
this and it now looks from the way the
Russians are are disposing of their
troops the Russians are asking
themselves the same question